uh you came into the studio and
you uttered the words development is key
interest 960 yeah take a stream through
that and just
uh that's it
so
are you looking at just 960 given the
fact that you don't rely on theory as
much as just going back to the basics
basically
i'd say that it's quite fun like to
analyze the starting position with uh
you know the guys around and to
you know to come up with some idea or
some opening concept
and that's probably what we never had a
chance to do because we were born like
now not like 200 years ago
uh in normal chess but yeah i mean the
analyzing is quite fun and playing is
also fun especially if you like if
you're in some games like today but uh
as from uk like uh
this okay 15 minutes before the round is
like something
i would i would say my favorite how do
you analyze position that you are given
for only like 15 minutes do you try to
go narrow deep with your analysis how
did you guys approach it no we just
you know
we just check if e4 works yeah
and then we calculate it yeah i mean
okay some
you know shuffle pistols around
it definitely felt like development was
key in this last game against hikaru
take us through the game a little bit
uh okay so first of all he dared to play
king's game against what i told him
king's
i mean he got like a winning position
out of the opening i think but then he
did something wrong so we came up with
this idea takes in 97
so preparing both e5 and d5 and f5 i
mean like normal developing move
so after 92 and d5
uh
takes
yeah somehow i'm not sure i think but
should be fine here because i get all
this development and
somehow you don't really want to play c4
here is white but because the king is on
b1 uh but maybe you should uh
and like but yeah still you don't want
to weaken your king so queen f3 was
something
knight f6 alright developing move h3
and here i just decided i don't know to
put all the pieces in in the center i'm
not sure if it's good we'll get back to
this game in just a second let's take a
look at furuja because things are
heating up go ahead and put it on your
board and we'll get uh
we'll get the comments of
nebo as well
shaq
shaq spoiled
a very promising looking attack he's got
a piece
but
as you've been showing the initiative is
so important nepo uh big advantage for
white you would say
but i i can't even see the position
maybe okay maybe the
the big position there you go
right now
okay but still he has an extra piece and
he's not getting mated here so that's
some good news for him
i mean uh
bishop f3 e2
a2 okay e2 okay probably
okay d6 is my suggestion yeah like the
six
but who knows what will happen yeah so
maybe like an extra queen isn't easy but
not enough to in this position
so this is i don't know like rook takes
g2 whatever
run away with okay okay one is uh you
know is the move of the master
for sure
okay let's see what happens okay so
probably two is uh not as good when we
like d6 was chilling here okay the six
is very typical
it's not as good like if you sit like
here but you know other boards is like
always you know what's going on you have
no idea what you're facing let's take a
look at what's up c7 takes d6 has
happened go ahead put it on your board
uh
the d7 is the problem
c7 takes d6
that's huge and i guess if you take then
probably queen a6 just finishes the game
yeah okay to pawn unfortunately it's too
slow in
other words i should find it right
bishop takes be seven zero we should be
seven but the taxi five isn't like is
like that clear
so you win a queen but uh i have
one two three pieces probably you might
get and you know like the bishop is the
best defender of a king so like i have
two bishops defending my king
yeah i mean
if it would be like a time scramble to
this is still another ah it could be it
could end like in any of three results
but
i'd say like some d5 i would i would
probably play d5 here but d5 blunders
like knight xd5 and in the position we
uh we we using the last after exchange
and the five like it's very nice but
knight d5 and then rook one suddenly
comes here
queen takes e5
one king gate two
the game goes on you still have to worry
about checkmate
yeah that's quite annoying question
first
yeah rook to d3 there's still a lot of
threats for yeah i mean okay it's like
it's completely i mean incredible
position so
i have no idea i frankly have no idea
what's happening but
none of them wouldn't happen actually
because
never mind they take c5 this is the
position we currently have on the board
so we might actually go into that oh
this section oh we have bishop takes b7
guys and d takes e5 on the board
dang wow
wow that's huge
but you do have to become materialistic
and not look at checkmate ideas after c6
queen to a6 right now go for the queen
bishop take c6 has to be played
c6 maybe just
how do we how do i play after c6 by the
way
i probably also can crunch to c7 yeah so
like i just do i play up this i just
stick to the you know
on this minefield yeah i stick to the
dark squares and that's how i like
that's how i escape
well
you do have uh two extra pieces so
that helps when you are not when you are
mated it might you know be not enough
even three extras okay this is like
probably shaq is now dreaming to make
you know this short fantasy short castle
yeah at some point
like teleport his king to whatever like
to g8 here okay just don't touch me
so bishop c6 is on the board
king c7 probably is forced right
yes he played otherwise it's
there goes
black's going to end up with three
pieces for the queen but still his king
is not okay well yeah maybe well
defended
all right d5 on the cecilia i
just let's move
my goodness
well queen b5 is very nice yeah like
threatening some queen a5 queen b8 rook
b7 first like
chase the king until
until resignation yeah probably
and the rook is hanging nepo it seems to
me that you like these kind of chaotic
positions uh
uh very much in your game do you by the
way
i think it was played d5 you have to
take i mean of course i like it after
okay
two years of playing petrov
[Laughter]
probably have to consider
or maybe like king d7 k7 but i'm afraid
this is like a little bit too
slow i think the seven is quite your
move i think yeah so that's three
temples
oh gates
anything that would be recommended for
maybe
one a6 c6 bishop a6 after king december
yeah
nope it's time when you get on the
running shoes king d7 knight takes
defaults
probably probably only one wow
rook f1 check
uh-huh
and again the the clock times of the
players if you don't mind one minute 43
seconds against two minutes for shock
you know probably okay all these
computer-ish moves but
looks like all these moves are so easy
because it's like i think like
it's exactly like his cup of tea such
positions
so everything is hanging
on
this is almost a study what is this
yes what the heck that stopped queen d6
yes sir that's about the concept of
developing yeah yeah g1 wasn't developed
you know but the bishop on d8 and the
bishop on c8 have not moved
but it's like you know it's like dean
iran won the game against fabio uh
against rapport i think with his bishop
on c8 and never moved never moved uh
between like 60 moves or something yes
exactly
so he's like we we made a cheer in
studio when he finally moved his bishop
it's like he remembered okay so how do
you continue this position now you go
queen eight and try to give some sort of
a check but okay check uh
i mean check is only a check here so no
one ever died from a check as they say
that's at least one because if i take on
g1 and they have rookie one check and
the and e1 also provides
also like uh maybe you notice it on the
camera like uh he got his queen yeah
he's moving his you know future queen
closer to him yeah
like to make sure it it won't run anyway
cc6
c6
what are we seeing
[Music]
no idea okay
that would be amazing the king will be
right
nice but you have one thing
i like it's a nice prophylactical move
probably there you have to take on f1
sometimes you have queen d5 27 queen b7
ping d5 and then rook takes f1 because
you take a front for the second time
maybe that's the idea behind
uh
but it's always better to have a queen
and don't have one
i guess great and drool
okay it's not an option because queen
takes e5 here like ends the game
immediately
okay that's a good point crucial moment
here and clocks again
yeah it's a
black has an extra pci in the variant
on c6
no i mean okay you want queens uh rook
b7 b should be seven queen d7 king b6
screen b7 king c5 queen
db5 king d6 rooker one queen before rook
d1 king d7 rook d7
uh
king e8
c7
bishop c7 and and another one yeah rook
c7 uh
rook b5
[Laughter]
do you feel like your experience from
2019 from the world championship matches
is giving you an edge in this tournament
i don't think uh like
we can seriously speak about experience
in official random chassis
uh it's
basically pretty much just like in some
rapid chats in other rapid chess it's uh
based on you know your you know how is
it going generally yeah so
this is going great yeah
your games are also you know going great
and vice versa
so
i'd say uh
speaking of the king's gambit yeah i
mean it was like quite in the opening
for me when i came i was making all
these courses uh and uh and lasted quite
quite a while
and
somehow i changed it
for you know for myself uh
the revelation of the material yeah so
let's say okay you play this catalan you
play king's gambit you get some other
lines and the pawn is not as like you
know it's not as important as it seems
here so like like when you play for
squares for the center and so on
probably we all know this since
childhood
uh but we never
okay we quite
you know we are not using this concept
too often yeah but it's always helpful
to play when you're feeling happy
yeah so yeah congratulations we'll see
you in the next couple of days
thank you but i also wanted to show you
online oh suddenly from my game because
i just wanted to check it if it like if
it exists or not
we have to catch the end of this game
but yes we can definitely keep you here
in the studio okay and then we'll look
at the game kingdom pattern game
it looks like a pawn breakthrough so
who's winning this one it seems like
black p5
you see faster
so you go c4
take take
[Music]
and
please quickly uh nepo show us the the
the line and yeah i was just curious so
let's say in this position he could play
instead of rook one he could play c3
move like 12. yes that was the key move
c3 i was expending and after c3 uh i was
creating something like you know
um
okay
knight
okay let's say knight f2
knight f2 yeah queen f2
bishop f5 bishop c2 takes
okay i understand this is a
co-cooperative variation but queen e4
yes takes queenie for check king d1
bishop h4
queen f3 and castles
yeah and if you take only four then i go
with knight e3 mate yeah but okay i
could be winning if not 94 i didn't see
94
that's enough i mean i was like very
excited okay wow like if i'm really
winning various of it i didn't really
trust myself but i felt like well it's
if it happens it would be quite nice but
yeah that's nice truth truth yours yeah
it never means
john congratulations thank you we'll uh
see you in the next